so i'm playing against the ocean storm a
russian grandmaster
and i'm gonna be cheeky enough to try
the rats again
really we you know
pushing my luck
e6 it's the whole point you just give up
this pawn and pretend that
nothing nothing's wrong
i think in this particular case the
truth is though that nothing
is particularly wrong yes he does win a
pawn
this way but i do think that black gets
decent play
24 what's the point here
nah i don't remember what you're
supposed to do so i'm just gonna do
something
something common sense
knight d7 knight f6
this way i'm winning a pawn back right
take on d4 and
my development is okay
i get to exchange the queens get an
ending where i have the bishop pair
life's good huh i think so
oh not bishop d7 king the 8 bishop f4
bishop d7
that's what i wanted to do
let's keep the tongue right in the mouth
as you say in english
bishop c7 king c8
he's got trouble with this knight knight
c7 rook cientis also got trouble with
this knight
so i assume yeah he was gonna he was
gonna castle and then
i can go a6 or i can go c6
don't know which way which one is best
oh a6 it goes knight c7 to d5
that makes it simple gotta go c6 then
i think now the knight drops back to c3
and although
oh this one i'm not too sure about
i really liked getting the square on d5
for the night
maybe i should go to h no i should go to
d5
um here i'm pretty happy with my bishop
there
i get a check everybody loves to check
right
and then key8 eventually i want to go f6
king f7
and just consolidate that way
okay let me go knight five
bring the knight the way
around can go f5 f4
what should i do here
if i go bishop c8
it's got rookie one which is a tad
annoying
it's got a bunch of activity here
okay i'm just gonna go for something
a little bit unusual here f5
just weakening a bunch of squares
most of all because i didn't really see
what to do and i gotta play faster
so i'm just gonna go we should see yeah
this
this thing this didn't work this didn't
work
at all
oh even as this one
that is quite
a vexing mess okay rook d6
fights fight fight fights
it's not that easy for him i got a
couple of bishops and
he's got a he's got to play fast in
order to win this
and also quite well
i mean he cannot spend time the way he
is now then
he's gonna get flying for sure
oh i blended this
i am my one own worst oh
that was nice i attacked two knights at
the same time
i was gonna say i am my own worst enemy
here but
i think he is also his worst enemy
he's just too slow
he is too slow
bring the bishop into the game oh there
we got a fork
no that was that was a bit of a collapse
by my opponent
okay that was like i was down 20 seconds
with the
last position and now at the end i was
up 20 seconds with a completely winning
position so
things can turn around quickly in these
games between